I think the thing I love most about
Sheree is I just love seeing a black
girl in the stem you know yam unity
because I mean it was kind of like how I
felt when I saw hidden figures Wow you
know I just love seeing that what did
what did you think when they approached
and said this is who you are
mm-hmm I was firstly I was blown away
simply by justice besides I got to do or
do addition sides I got which I couldn't
kind of pick up the fact that she was
very smart you know super intelligent
super interested in you know technology
and all of that so firstly that was
pulling me in because we I hardly see
characters like this so that allowed me
to be interested so I knew that if I was
blessed to play this role then it would
mean a lot because it would put
something out into the world that would
be of inspiration to other other women
other young girls as well so altogether
it was amazing to find out can I tell
you you steal oh man no I say everybody
did a good job baby no seriously I was
like I was googling you just like blow
it like freaking out I'm just I
personally think it bless you guys for
all the amazing like feedback especially
from the premiere as well but it's just
I'm just super grateful to him to be a
part of it with such an amazing cast I
feel like you know I'm really proud to
be with them but thank you that was very
kind of you I think we can consider her
a Disney Princess because she is the
princess of Wakanda yes this is a Disney
movie yeah I think we need to say Sheree
is it
I think a lot of people have been doing
that online and I'm hey hey man can I
say no I just I'm just gonna make shy of
an I be a home boo princess no
interpretation because I know she does
it to keep that home but hey I saw you
home yeah I was clapping sorry cuz I
think every one of us have had that boo
yeah that moment it's just so relatable
like no matter where you are in the
world of them especially as a person you
know a black president I saw something
that you know it yeah it's like you're
in your room and they call you like it's
like when my mom shots my name I'm like
did I wash the dishes did I take out the
trash like I was meant to like
something's gone wrong
it was better you know by the toes yeah
what was it like playing opposite of
Chadwick because you really like I've
felt so much chemistry and so much
authenticity between two of you guys oh
man from the very beginning of like
doing the auditions and I felt really
strongly in my spirit that he would be
an amazing person to play my brother and
to be his sister and I really just thank
God for it because it was just it just
came really really easy because he's
such a he's a soul brother like if you
looked look at his work yes Jackie
Robinson he's gonna have to play himself
in a biopic say you know he does a lot
of he's great I and he's a soulful
brother so I feel I feel like it came
easily for me to connect with him and
and that naturally just happened and
actually have a genuine love and
appreciation for him as my big brother
and I look up to him and I respect him
so much even to be the lead of this film
and
and Allah so well he there's there's
characters on both spectrums you know
and he's in the middle in the center
just just keeping it alive and keeping
it balanced and keeping it so well so so
well put together so yeah like those
scenes came really really easily we just
had fun
the fight scenes were so intense and and
I can't even imagine the kind of
training you guys had but who do you
think who was the most natural fighter
on set natural fighter dunno because
obviously with the walking dead she's
got some some experience kicking but
yeah
Sochi would that one set as well so
naturally she was the one that was
really good at fighting as well and also
I would say Chad he does a lot of
martial arts there's enough but
different types different fighting
techniques that I see him doing said I
tried to copy myself without trying to
get her so they I would look at what
they're doing and they would put that
into that character such a little sister
thing ya know literally I would do that
like I would see him practicing with
with Maurice ISM his trainer and then I
would go over to Maurice when they're
done it'd be like can you teach me and
then I would I would kind of master a
little bit I'll kind of get good at it
and then I feel like okay I got one up
on him like I know something that he
knows and it's just naturally wanting to
be like her brother again okay so we
know you're in infinity war yes what has
it been like being on that set versus
being unlocked intersect man firstly
they got a whole lot there's huge like
craft services we we were good like
Black Panther was amazing but it's just
because the cost of infinity was so big
we were trying to fit all those the
different schedules in and and different
actors but I just found that it was
amazing to to be with everybody you know
I'd be like oh snap that's um that's
so-and-so and that's so-and-so at so I
can't tell you what seems I'm gonna be
in with who keep that
for me may the fourth I think or
whatever it's gonna be out in May but it
was amazing just to be on that set it's
real energy real vibes and good vibes
and yeah I'm excited for people to see
that so that's crazy we have a black
panther movie out and then a couple
months time we have another Marvel movie
out it's just amazing amazing time and
what Conda is very strong then very well
in the trailer you see them talking
about what kinda Chadwick like both with
the entire New Avengers we've opened up
a lot to these people so what are you
gonna help them out and help fight some
battles and hopefully it makes the
Marvel Universe an even greater place
than it already is right now
so because we see or kinda in infinity
war and we know you guys are talking
about it you're in it how many more
Black Panther movies well if you guys go
out and help us to get a great
box-office breakthrough to the point of
breaking it to the point of reaching
star wars there we can discuss that
further